[Music]
this is for
joe and bart i think he actually is more
for david so but he's not here so
you guys can you can is it about
hamburgers i could channel my inner
david
okay so this is a form of punishment
that uh parents have been using in china
oh and it is a it's a guy
what's his name he's a guy he's a guy
his name is
uh
okay um i'm not going to try to
pronounce the province
but he zijing okay i got you okay
so he pretends to be uh the
the bad uncle to kids and so when the
kids are like i'm not gonna brush my
teeth the parents are like
oh i'm gonna call up the bad uncle so he
should the parents bring up uh
the video of him and the guy is just
like threatening them and making
menacing faces and like
basically saying if you don't brush your
teeth i'm gonna come and get you
i'm gonna take you away yeah exactly
it's awesome
it's like the boogie man but like trying
to make it more it's actually called the
boogie man
yeah say the mailman down the street was
going to take me
called the bad uncle i'll show you a
video damn
in asia they probably think that this is
one step above you love it
they're like we don't have to hit our
kids we just have to traumatize them
this is awesome
oh wait wait hold on that guy is kind of
funny because he looks like that dragon
ball you did his face
so well thank you now that i saw the
expression
you did it so well that was spot-on
it always makes me laugh when people
talk with their forehead first like he's
trying to scare him with the forehead
[Music]
what is he saying bart
[Music]
listening can you pause it real quick so
he was just saying like if uh
like if you uh keep playing with your
ipad
i'm gonna go to your house why did you
have to listen the same way he was
talking to you because i'm trying to
like
connect with them he was like if his
head goes lower so does my head
when he listens to you he will mirror
with his lips he'll
copy what he would mumble his lips as
he's listening to you i was
looking at him and i was seeing his face
there i was like
what bart was gonna play with you he'd
be next to you doing your lines like
it's like wizard of oz and on the line
and i'm doing the tin man's lines
because he's doing every character's
line until it's his turn so everyone in
the front rows was like jesus man
come on someone put the lion away
it's taking me out of it yeah so he's 27
years old and
who's 27 years this guy yeah that guy's
27
was 27. he looks like he's 40 something
bald people got it rough like that dude
that's why i'm a hat guy now i'm a hat
guy big time
he first did this with his like his
nephew
and then it was such a hit that his mom
started
telling all her friends god you can buy
an angry uncle
so you can buy a video from him this is
like the services where you can pay like
a celebrity to say something
kind of yeah but he runs his own little
site
and tries to do that with leia like i'm
gonna tell uncle joe and then she looks
at me like
and laughs so like literally she doesn't
give a
[ __ ] i'm terrified of kids like that
because you gotta work to find what they
love
listen i'm gonna take myself he already
revealed himself though
yeah i'm not scary yeah i feel like
they're too thirsty now the kids are
like i have both of them on my leg all
day long and i'm like man
let me go is aunt like putting random
punishments
in your mouth like he's like yeah
uncle's gonna catch you yeah
i'm just like that's tight i'm awesome
my sister definitely put that one and
put one of those on me and i had to tell
my niece i was like listen
mom's really disappointed in you and
she's like
you can't stay over you can't stay to
aunt you can't come to auntie's house
mom said
she was like i was like is that good
i was telling my sister i was like like
this she's like yeah i was like
fix what's wrong with your mom or you
can't come to auntie's house ever again
wow that's hard but she was hiding food
she was hiding food under the bed dude i
would backstab the parents so
fast because i want the kids approval
yeah that's dude
might know but my niece i was like i'm
like
leverage right i'm like but baby you got
to listen to mom or you can't mom said
you cannot come
you can't come she's like but okay i was
like chrissy if you don't [ __ ] let
this daughter come over to my house
i was like she's gonna hate me i was
like she better come over next week
because
i need her to love me because nobody
loves me and this is breaking my heart
but like you're getting punished
yeah you take her away from me i have
nothing else besides a dog and joe
that's all you need though that's all
you need i can't really connect i have
many cats though and so i can connect to
you through cats so
so i am the cat bad guy daddy
daddy huh anything that goes down the
cats
run to me they run behind my legs
they're like i'm like their protector
i'm like i gotta take you to the vet
i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry but i have the
cages and then they're like
no protective they run they run to me
and then you grab them and put them in
the cage
but you grab somebody give them to me i
give them to her to put them in the
cages because they already they already
hate love her the most it's like this oh
i love you so much
just drop a cat and just run away it's
her fault so that's how i relate to you
i i had that with my nephews but like
in the positive reinforcement way i
guess because whenever they didn't want
to do [ __ ] their parents would always be
like
look he's doing it like are you don't
you want to do it because oh you're the
example
or they'll be like hey hey do the things
so that like they'll do it okay okay
they're like look he's doing it look or
like oh just tell them to do it
they listen to you that was the phrase
they always said they listened to you
i'd be like do do the thing your mom
says i'm pretty sure my sister's
probably sitting there and be like don't
do
anything your auntie does will you just
say that
kids think i'm cool like listen kids
think i'm cool what can i do
they do they do what can i say it's the
good
hair you got really good hair doesn't
mean it does have good hair
oh yeah he's a mop up there dude it's
really it was really shiny i saw it
earlier i'm like is it too forward if i
give him a compliment
no it's vital sassoon up in there ah it
looks like it smells nice
it's a good color too did you dye it
just recently uh not recently i like i
i sprayed some of the stuff that makes
it lighter like a few months ago
do you do that he's like but that was
months ago does it curl on top right
actually
yeah i have curly hair you you have
really great hair
too oh thank you so you don't get upset
that it gave him to come i was getting
kind of red but that's okay
yeah you guys get a room
we're in one oh true we should leave we
should go
we should would you do this with taika
no
[Laughter]
no he he kind of has his own like what
he wants to do
yeah so i gotta kind of just like
nurture it or kind of like
slowly like put him on track like if
he's
he he's like this kid like clean up your
toys then he'll just start dancing
around and moving away
but if i'm like um like he let's see if
he wants to play with me and i start
putting things away and i make it look
really fun and he goes ah
papa cleaned the room i'm like yeah he
starts cleaning too oh yeah
so he's super down to do things it just
has to be put in a way that
is yeah what makes him like to do he has
to be manipulated
exactly it makes you nervous to think
about possibly having another one
like i know so my nieces are very
different
yeah very different and like how they
behave and things that work for one and
doesn't work for another
do you ever worry about that day that
you're going to have to figure out
another one no i'm actually already
relieved because i had the devil first
so it doesn't get any worse than that
yeah you think it won't get worse i
don't think so
taika because taika is is like so
me being toned down and trying to stay
uh uh in a way where i my career isn't
in trouble
in front of the camera taika is a
hundred percent like me
all the time so his ultimate troll [ __ ]
around
it's grandma if grab like let's say
grandma makes taika do something right
the man she's watching tv the minute
grandma turns around
he'll change the channel and hide the
rope mount now and he's three years old
so just how much of a troll he is i'm
like that sounds like all of your
childhood stories
exactly i'm like this guy is here with
none of the punishment yeah
yeah like this guy is exactly like me so
i'm like the next one will probably be
more like geo and more
like obedience and you've already been
through hell so you're
the other one's going to be easy i feel
the same way about cats i was like
i was like this first cat i'm never
getting another cat but then we got a
bunch of guests and i'm like oh the
person is just so different they're
actually like
almost like people they actually have
their own personalities and like they're
all unique
see they said that cat ladies could
never get married but you just gotta
turn your husband into a cat lady yeah
did you have the cats before you had the
husband yes
we had two dads but well they were yours
yeah
we did nothing then i was living alone
with two cats and then we moved in
and he adopted them into his home too
but i had them for a few years before
him and so they just follow me around
all day but
um now we got seven cats and some of
them like
more yeah so he's like experiencing the
like love first
hand right now we're gonna get dogs too
and they can chase each other we're cat
people we don't
we don't i don't appreciate that i don't
appreciate that i like dogs but just
they're too loud my home girl she had
one cat and then she acquired another
cat's cat needed
a friend and i brought my dog over which
is you know
one of three so i have two two other
dogs they live somewhere else
you're a dog lady like a helicopter i've
been my my parents keep telling me stop
getting in relationships and stop
getting dogs
like every relationship i have had a dog
oh no yeah i had had uh
a rottweiler alright r.i.p cali
and then i have bain and kala which they
live somewhere else and then i have onyx
and i took onyx which is my newest son
he's mine
solo parenting you can meet him one day
okay and then i took him over to my
friend's house who she is single and
she's acquired two cats well guess what
my dog tried to eat her cat
and the thing was is that onyx is really
sweet but
she's i don't know i don't think that
all cat people are the same she's semi
like
i think she really is a dog person but
it's just so busy but she treats her
cats kind of like
dogs yeah like these cats got attitude
they kind of hard like these are some
like savage cats
yeah like they don't [ __ ] around so i
was surprised that the cat didn't beat
my dog's ass but like as soon as i
brought him over i was like oh yeah can
he stay let's go out we're gonna
do single parent things cause that's all
we got and
onyx got off the leash went and tacked
her cat and the cat ended up on the
on the like window oh and she was like
listen i love you
but dog can't come anymore and i'm like
so your dog's big too but imagine like
if you guys have kids and your kids
don't get along
like what's going to happen when you
guys have kids and then everybody tries
to hang out and your kids start fighting
each other
you know what's cute as [ __ ] taika and
isaac love each other
it's not seeing each other in a while
and they see they just they're just
glued to each other like taika is
hugging them
isaac's being big brother just playing
with them they're just watching ipads
together
that's pretty cool but like what if what
if tyka doesn't like the seven cats like
are you gonna be able to he didn't like
the cat talk oh he didn't he was
uninterested
yeah he came into the room he was like
or like you want to see kitties and
we're like he's like yeah and then he
gets in there he's like
and he's like trying to get out again
he's like i don't know
well you're like you can't bring tyka
around here anymore yeah i was offended
i was reminded
how does that happen are you guys ready
for that for like what if your kids
don't get along he doesn't even like our
dog
like fan will come and like kiss like ty
can he's like
get away fine get away tiger's gonna be
off like this what's up y'all
i'm good stupid animals living my life
our kids are gonna like everybody they
better
are dog kids
[Music]
you